-Republicans chose
Congressman Steve Scalise
as their party's nominee
for Speaker of the House today,
but it's still not clear
if he actually has enough
votes to become speaker.
Many Republicans have criticized
the party's chaotic process,
calling it absurd
and a mess.
Also, one of those Republicans,
George Santos,
just got charged again
with even more alleged crimes.
For more on this,
it's time for A loser Look.
[ Cheers and applause ]
After deposing now former House
Speaker Kevin McCarthy last week
and setting off
a chaotic chain of events,
the House GOP
has finally selected
a new nominee for speaker,
but that doesn't mean
he'll actually become
the next speaker of the House
because, as we've learned
many times,
Republicans can definitely
still screw things up.
-There was a big vote
among Republicans
in the House today
to determine a new speaker,
and the GOP's nomination
for speaker
has gone
to Steve Scalise,
the Republican congressman
from Louisiana,
winning the GOP's nomination
for speaker
on a secret ballot.
-This is no guarantee
that Steve Scalise
will be the next speaker
of the House.
Republicans are still divided
as to how to take this process
to the floor of the House
of Representatives.
Already, there are members
of the Republican conference
telling my colleague
Ali Vitali
that they will not vote
for Steve Scalise
on the floor of the House
if and when
this speaker nomination
actually makes it
to that stage.
So the math is still a problem
for these Republican candidates.
-Yes, math is still a problem
for Republicans.
For example,
they're still not sure
if 306 is more than 232.
And, as we've seen before,
winning -- winning
the GOP nomination for speaker
definitely does not mean you
will actually become speaker.
It's kind of like an actor
getting a callback
for a bit part on "Succession".
You didn't actually
get the part yet,
and even if you do,
you'll probably
just get yelled at,
[Bleep] can by the end
of the episode.
By the way, Scalise voted
to overturn the 2020 election,
and in interviews, he's refused
to state without equivocation
that Joe Biden won
and the election was not stolen.
He's also refused to say that
Donald Trump was responsible
for the coup attempt,
an insurrection, on January 6th.
-When you met
with the former president,
did you ask him
to take responsibility?
Did he take responsibility?
-Well, Jonathan,
I was in Florida
doing some fundraising
throughout a number
of parts of Florida.
I ended up at Mar a Lago,
and the president reached out,
and we visited.
-No one just ends up
at Mar a Lago.
That's like telling your spouse
after a guy's trip,
"We just went to a movie,
got dinner,
and one thing led to another,
and we ended up
at the Playboy Mansion.
It happens."
Mar a Lago is a place you go to
for one of three reasons --
kiss up to Trump,
a real bad wedding,
or if you're a foreign spy,
looking at over here,
our nation's nuclear secrets
at the dinner buffet.
Side note -- what a plum gig
to be a spy sent to Mar a Lago.
I mean, you don't have to know
how to break into a safe
or avoid those
crisscross lasers.
You never have to put on
a "Mission Impossible" mask.
You just walk in the front door
and say,
[Foreign accent] "Anyone here
know anything about submarines?"
And the next thing you know,
[Imitating Trump]
"I actually know quite a lot,
and I've got pictures of him
I'd love to show you.
I'd love to show them to you."
[ Applause ]
"Before, I just want to make
sure you are an American."
[Foreign accent]
"Yes, yes. From Cincinnati."
[ Laughter ]
"Go Bengals."
[ Laughter, applause ]
[ Normal voice ]
And as if things couldn't get
any more chaotic
for Republicans,
congressmen --
and according to him --
Taylor Swift's real boyfriend,
George Santos,
just got charged again
for allegedly
stealing campaign money
and lying about basically
every part of his life.
-Federal prosecutors hit
embattled
Congressman George Santos
with an array of stunning
new criminal charges,
including wire fraud
and identity theft.
The new accusations
were made
in a 23 count
superseding indictment.
-Republican Congressman
George Santos
now faces more criminal charges.
And these include wire fraud,
falsifying records,
and identity theft.
That's among other crimes.
Prosecutors now accusing Santos
of being involved
in a credit card scheme
where the campaign
would charge contributors
credit cards repeatedly
and above
the federal contribution limits.
-He illegally charged
their credit cards.
He's less like a member
of Congress
and more like
a telemarketer scam
your grandpa would fall for.
[Imitating old man]
"The man said if I gave him
my credit card, he'd send me
gold bars in the mail.
I believed him because
he's a star volleyball player.
Who would lie
about such a thing?"
[ Normal voice ]
Is there a crime George Santos
hasn't been accused of?
I'm just waiting for the day
you watch the news
and prosecutors say Santos
illegally charged
donors credit cards,
stole their identities,
and refused to pick up
his dog's poop.
And also, it wasn't his dog,
it was a cat dressed as a dog,
which he used to pretend
he was blind
to get preferential
seating on an airplane,
which he paid
for using fake bills
that he printed
at a Kinko's, a Kinko's,
which he broke into at night
using a golf club
he claimed was a gift
from Tiger Woods,
but which, in fact,
he stole from a child
at a putt putt course.
And it won't surprise you
to learn that Santos
did not want to discuss
these latest charges.
Here he is once again
being chased down
the halls of Congress
by a group of reporters
claiming he didn't even know
about the charges
because he didn't have access
to his phone.
-No comment. I was -- I did not
have access to my phone.
I have no clue.
-Prosecutors say you defrauded
the American public.
Will you resign?
-I have no clue of what you guys
are talking about.
No, I will not. Excuse me.
-They said that you
stole people's identities.
Did you steal
people's identities?
Did you commit identity fraud?
-Are you still gonna vote
at the speakers election?
-What do you have to say
to your constituents?
-Will you step down?
-I will not.
I have no comment.
I was in conference like
everyone else, without my phone,
so I have nothing to talk about.
I need to take a look at --
-Did you commit wire fraud?
That was a pretty
basic question.
-First of all,
when this is over,
Santos is either going
to be in jail
or running the last leg
of the U.S. relay team.
I mean, no member of Congress
has ever gotten
so much cardio out of the job.
Second, there's no way
that's a real phone call.
The screen does look
like a phone call,
but when you zoom into it,
it says
"Fake call
to ignore reporters."
[ Laughter ]
Nothing sums up George Santos
more than claiming
he didn't have access
to his phone
while talking on his phone.
Unless that's not his phone
and he stole it
from someone's grandpa.
[ Imitating old man ]
"Joke's on you.
I'll just buy a new one
when I get my gold bars.
Thank you, volleyball man."
[ Normal voice ] Also,
not having access to your phone
is such a lame excuse.
It's a 23 count indictment,
not a text from your mom.
Maybe one of your aides could,
I don't know, come up,
give you a heads up.
I've been interrupted
during meetings
for way less important things.
One time, I was in the middle
of a meeting
about our show's budget,
and someone from wardrobe
came in to ask me if I wanted
to try on the cicada headpiece.
And then I turn on C-Span
and [Bleep] George Santos
is wearing it.
[ Laughter ]
So one of the GOP's members
has been indicted again,
as Republicans embark on yet
another chaotic fight
over the next speaker.
It hasn't even been a year
since Republicans won a very
small majority in the House,
and in that time,
they've seen indictments
and humiliating scandals
and nearly broken out
into physical fighting
multiple times.
You might recall
that in January,
one Republican member
of Congress
had to be restrained
by his face
from lunging at
a Republican colleague
during a late night
vote for speaker.
And then, a fellow
Republican explained
that moment in a way that made
it even more embarrassing.
Again, this is a Republican
member of Congress
talking about his fellow
Republican congressman.
Quote...
Interesting fact, rednecks are
the only members of Congress
legally allowed to drink
on the House floor.
This is true.
If you bring a bourbon
on the House floor,
you'll be ordered to leave,
unless you know
the first names
of both Duke boys
and the car they drove.
[ Southern accent ] "The member
from Kentucky is out of order
unless he can name
the main characters
from the 'Dukes of Hazzard'."
"Bo and Luke
and the General Lee. Whoo.
Them boys was crazy."
[ Normal voice ]
You may proceed.
Seriously, calling Republicans
drunk rednecks
is the kind of thing even I
couldn't say about Republicans.
Like, if we put that in
an early draft of A Closer Look
and then read through it,
I'd get a note
from one of our producers
saying that joke might be
insensitive to alcoholics,
Republicans, and rednecks.
And look, I'm not going to say
who that producer is,
but her name rhymes
with blemily blerotas,
who's very sensitive
because she's from Indianapolis,
which doesn't mean
she's a redneck.
It just means they're definitely
within driving distance.
So...
[ Laughter ]
That was back in January.
Then last week, Republicans
erupted in chaos again
and deposed their short
lived speaker, Kevin McCarthy.
And again, they nearly
came to blows.
-Jake, I'll be really candid.
I think if we had
stayed together
in the meeting last night,
I think that you would
have seen fists thrown.
And I'm not being dramatic
when I say that.
There is a lot of raw emotions
right now.
-Booze, fighting,
and raw emotions.
Is this Congress
or an Irish wake?
You think you miss Sheamus?
"I miss Sheamus
more than you, boy-o.
Now, let's take it outside.
And remember,
no grabbing of the face.
This isn't Congress."
I can't imagine
another workplace
where you're allowed to say
good thing we ended that meeting
because we're about to beat
the [Bleep] out of each other.
Like, again, I know I would
immediately get a call from HR
if I said something like that
after a pitch meeting
with my writers.
Although, if my writers land
a punch like they land a joke,
then I got nothing
to worry about.
[ Laughter ]
Oh, don't take this out.
I'll take 'em all on.
The depths of the GOP's
insanity were on full display
yesterday when South Carolina
Congresswoman Nancy Mace
showed up to the House
GOP meetings wearing a shirt
with a giant letter
A on it.
Mace voted to oust
McCarthy last week,
and she said
she was wearing the shirt
as a response to all
the attacks against her.
-Congresswoman Nancy Mace,
she had a new letter.
Wearing a T-shirt
with a big red letter "A".
She was one of the Republicans
who ousted Kevin McCarthy.
-I'm wearing the Scarlet letter
after the week
that I just had last week,
being a woman up here
and being demonized for my vote
and for my voice.
-Did Republicans also ban
the book "The Scarlet Letter"?
Because clearly
you haven't read it.
The A stands for "adulterer",
not, as I presume
you're using it, "A-hole".
Also, if memory serves,
the A was a mark of humiliation,
not a fashion statement.
Hester Prynne wasn't
walking around Boston
with a scarlet letter
pinned to her chest going,
[ English accent ]
"Oh, check me out.
I just had an illicit affair
during Puritan times.
Jealous much?"
[ Normal voice ] And look,
I know people didn't
have that accent in the 1600's,
but isn't it fun
to think they did?
All great literature
that took place in New England
can be enhanced
if you imagine
the people were talking
like that.
"The Crucible" --
[English accent] "This town
is [Bleep] crawling
with witches, kid."
[ Normal voice ]
"Little women" --
[English accent]
What's up with Beth?
She looks pekid.
[ Normal voice ]
"Ethan Frome" --
[English accent] Look who
the cat dragged in.
Ethan [Bleep] Frome.
[ Normal voice ] I've never
read that book, so I don't...
[ Laughter ]
[ English accent ] "Yo, Ethan."
[ Normal voice ]
Seriously, though, Nancy Bass,
you look like you just walked
out of a school play
or a football game.
Somewhere, there's a group
of Packers fans missing an A
who are very upset.
And even anchors
are having a hard time
taking Republicans seriously.
Here's CNN's Jake Tapper
reacting to Mace's PR stunt.
-Congresswoman Nancy Mace
walked in with a letter A
on her shirt as she walked
into closed doors.
She was asked by her colleague,
Annie Grayer,
what that was about.
She said it was
a Scarlet Letter.
Jake.
-Okay.
That's not making me convinced
that they have
their act together.
Damn, you just got sassed
by Jake Tapper,
AKA, you just got tapped.
-Tapped.
[ Horns blow ]
[ Electrical guitar plays ]
[ Laughter ]
-I do wish news anchors
were more sarcastic.
It's fun to imagine
Walter Cronkite
using that same tone
to report on Apollo 11.
[ Sarcastic tone ] "American
astronauts successfully
landed on the moon,
which scientists say is almost
as charmless and dusty
as yo mama."
[ Laughter ]
[ Normal voice ]
And the dysfunction
isn't just paralyzing
the GOP conference,
it's threatening to paralyze
the entire U.S. government.
Again, here is a Republican
member of Congress
explaining the stakes
of this GOP leadership dispute.
-Funding the government
is part of our fundamental duty,
and we can't even do that.
So... And now, here we are
at the 11th hour
with a clock ticking,
and we can't even see a speaker.
Man, that says volumes.
At first,
it was somewhat comical.
Now, it's on -- it's bordering
on the -- on the absurd.
-Bordering on the absurd.
One of your members
is walking around
like a [Bleep]
"Sesame Street" character
who hangs out near Oscar's
trash cans selling drugs.
"Hey, hey, hey, Elmo.
You want to get high?
The A stands
for amphetamines."
Now, even Republicans
are admitting in public
they're incapable
of governing.
Again, that's not me
saying that.
I'm sure there's some viewers
who accidentally tune
into this show and think,
"Oh, there's Myers ranting again
about how Republicans
suck at their jobs."
But this time,
it's not me saying it.
It's a Republican saying it.
In fact, I'm going to repeat
those exact words
you just heard from that
Republican congressman,
but I'm going to do it like
it's the intro to A Closer Look
in a segment we're calling
See If You Can Tell
the Difference Between
Seth Talking About
Republicans and Republicans
Talking about Republicans.
Alright. Here we go.
Funding the government is part
of the Republican Party's
fundamental duty,
and they can't even do that.
So now, here we are at the 11th
hour with the clock ticking,
and they can't even see
the speaker, which says volumes.
At first, it was
somewhat comical.
Now, it's bordering
on the absurd.
For more on this,
it's time for A Closer Look.
Nancy Mace, what grade
do we get for that bit?
Yes!
[ Laughter, applause ]
So...
[ Cheers and applause ]
Republicans have,
by their own admission,
paralyzed one chamber
of Congress
because of their ineptitude
and dysfunction.
They're admitting to the world
they're not
a serious governing party,
and still, no one can predict
when this pointless
melodrama will end.
On the bright side,
maybe they'll finally
have enough downtime to read
that book they love about
a woman named...
-"Scarlet Letter".
-[ Chuckles ]
[ Laughter ]
This has been A Closer Look.